la guerra en ucrania está teniendo un
impacto más allá de sus fronteras el
conflicto ha provocado la paralización
de las exportaciones de trigo ya que
tanto moscú como kiev son dos de los
mayores exportadores de este cereal en
el mundo algunos de los países más
empobrecidos del planeta se están viendo
afectados
en 45 países africanos y menos
desarrollados importante al menos un
tercio de su trigo de ucrania o rusia 18
de estos países importando al menos el
50 por ciento esto incluye países como
burkina faso egipcio república
democrática del congo líbano libia
somalia ciudad y yemen somalia sudán en
diamante aunque los precios del trigo se
han visto golpeados en un primer momento
podría provocar la subida de los costos
de otros alimentos desde que inició el
conflicto los precios de la energía y la
agricultura se han disparado el fondo
monetario internacional advirtió que la
situación podría empeorar impulsando aún
más la inflación el programa mundial de
alimentos también afirma que el desvío
de fondos hacia la crisis ucraniana ha
agotado su asignación para el resto del
mundo
ya estamos tan escasos de fondos y ahora
con ucrania tenemos un 50 por ciento de
raciones para la gente por ejemplo en
yemen acabo de cortar el 50 por ciento
de raciones para 8 millones de personas
níger 50% de raciones y 50% de raciones
y el 50% no tiene nada es que están en
extrema necesidad de lifetime ni el
director de la fao dice que es urgente
que los agricultores ucranianos vuelvan
a los campos los peores efectos de la
crisis en la economía mundial podrían
sentirse en los próximos años